[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
be pleased I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Chinatown New York City rum joined
by Mike Chen you know Mike from his
popular YouTube channel Strictly
dumpling where this globe-trotting
gourmand
explores some of the most sought-after
dishes in the cities like Hong Kong
Tokyo Bangkok and of course New York
City oh oh that's one of the best things
I ever had oh that's so 4:40
deliciousness and that's why we're here
at nom Watty parlor the oldest dim sum
shop in the five boroughs to get a crash
course and one of the most celebrated
meals in the entire world all right Mike
before we start can you give us sort of
basic guide to dim sum the style of
eating the word dim sum is quite
interesting because different parts of
China have different understanding of
what that term means like another China
dim sum means the N XI which literally
means touching your heart they're
supposed to really speak to your soul
you know I mean in the southern China is
they call it a young chop which in
mandarin is you basically means drinking
tea because that's the whole thing you
know a lot of people watching this and
when they think dim sum they might think
that it's just the dumpling but that's
not the tea is almost just as important
it's incredibly important and also
there's like a science behind it I mean
you're supposed to get green tea for the
summer because it's better for cooling
down the body supposed to get darker tea
for the winter because it's better for
warming up the body if there's a
grandfather sitting next to us I'm gonna
pour him first because he's the elder
person when I pour you your tea you're
supposed to do something for me
so all you got to do is take your two
fingers here and just tap the table a
couple times or your knuckles so you've
gotta do that to show that you
appreciate me pouring the team
there's a lot going on here so someone
has been around the block yeah times how
do you decode this so typically there's
a couple types of them some places one
is if you come to a place like Nam wahoo
has a menu you can check it off the more
traditional places will have their cart
when the car comes try to ask for the
steamer from the bottom because that's
usually the hottest one what are the
traps in the menu I tend to stay away
from any stir-fried noodle dish or rice
dish these things really fill you up
specially if you take a whole plate of
noodles down let's go after this menu I
think that we should get the classics
okay
yeah and then I think that we should
push the boundaries a little bit okay
well and we definitely have to get the
chicken teeth there we go oh thank you
oh this is not intimidating at all where
do we start
these are steamed rice noodles and they
come in both shrimp and fried dough so I
think we should do the shrimp first okay
so typically like I mean if you're close
with the people you're you're eating
with you can also serve them with dim
sum I just met you today so let's get
don't know each other first let's talk a
little more before we start eating each
other um go ahead dip down a little bit
bad oh yeah you go bond that coupon that
how's that for you the bombing on that
is important oh yeah you need this sweet
soy sauce again this is not a regular
soy son we do regular soy sauce it's
gonna be become way too salty little
sweet soy sauce this becomes really
clean really nice this is one of my
favorite things in the world
inside is sweets salted eggs there's
really no distinction between this earth
and savory items and them so you can
give whatever whatever you can eat I
respected the reason why we're not
drinking cold water when that cold water
hits your stomach after you eat some
greasy food that's gonna congeal so you
want to chase it with some team it's
gonna help your digestion it's gonna
help you eat longer here let me let me
top you up here you never want to let
your guests T like get too long well
we're out at sea sha so here's something
you need to do okay take the tea led
put it upside down and that's gonna
signal to the server that we need more
teeth another round
[Music]
this of course is probably one of the
most famous than some items most people
come here they know to water shall mine
I mean is kind of just like a little
stuffed wonton egg wrappers on the
outside
pork usually on the inside it looks like
some roll on the top the flavor of the
pork really stands out that's a
beautiful flavor because cut fatty okay
that's nice like nice and bacony what
are you doing there's only one piece
left
no one should actually reach for the
last one I would typically offer to
somebody might be like Shawn eat this
because I know you want it but the one
thing you do not do is you do not offer
to cut this in half really no we don't
do that no no no last piece somebody
gets it go halfsies so one more left and
it's the headliner
it's the much-talked-about
much-discussed chicken feet situation
you never had this before first time now
the texture is a lot of times something
that people have a tough time getting
over basically the rule is if you break
down whatever you can't shoot eat that
everything I'll eat it I mean it's it
gets ugly it's a lot of people just put
in and I was holding their mouth and
just like just figure out what they're
talking but if you want to be more
civilized just eat the outside a little
bit
[Music]
and don't don't be afraid to use your
hands - hey good job man
I am impressed good deboning skills
there's nothing that turns me off about
the flavor mhm it's just the mental
hurdles that you have to jump in your
head the mark against it though is it's
so difficult to eat you know there's
like 30 different bone shards in my
mouth but I would recommend it I would
order it again
chicken feet no big deal I think when it
comes to dim sum you never tried them
some before you have to get it's like a
rite of passage I think that everybody
thinks of the flavor profiles in Chinese
food a very specific way yeah but if
I've learned anything today that you
know sometimes it does veer off that
road and a pretty significant way that's
real great about Chinese food we could
just drive across China I eat something
completely different every single meal
so we'll finish this in the meantime
stop by strictly dumpling watch Mike
just chew his way through the entire
world snack in one city at a time thanks
so much
[Music]